j'adorerais vous faites très bien les
actions du sud ou à temps et que ça peut
te [ __ ]
[Rires]
vraiment il ya des extra-terrestres pas
qu'ils vivent
on voit la paille dans le public et on a
ou bien moi que peut-être que je suis un
voilà je sais pas en fait oui il faut se
souvenir que la vie est apparue sur la
tête 3 milliards 800 millions d'années
je sais que tu es là c'est le résultat
je les résultats de quoi dans le long
processus qui est un processus à la fois
physique chimique ou biologique
mais ce qui s'est passé sur la terre il
ya premier à 83 milliards 8 et 4
milliard 2 c'est nécessairement passer
ailleurs nécessaire mais je veux dire
que c'est inévitable pour que les lois
sont physiquement universel tu sais ce
qu'on vient de découvrir maintenant
grâce au télescope spatial il vient de
découvrir qu'au lieu d'avoir 100
milliards de galaxies y en a 1000
milliards sur la vie de ma mère me
alexis milliards de galaxies et 250
milliards d'étoilés en cas d'accident
pouvoir le nombre d'accords et les
chiffres c'est bon c'est morrow non mais
igor et grichka la question c'est est-ce
que si on a parmi nous mais oui
franchement les extras dans la dans la
vie de tous les jours dès maintenant
non mais franchement du mal vous êtes
sérieux non pas qu il y en a oui alors
ils savent paris via des extra
terrestres parmi nous
[Rires]
merci et franchement mais il me faut
désormais nous après les gars qu'est ce
qu'il y a écrit j'ai tout dit on l'a
perdu quand on l'a perdue à un moment
j'adorerais vous ferez bien les actions
du sud ou et que ça peut te [ __ ] si on
me parlait d'une invention mais avec
l'accent du sud i gr allez-y time
machine qui fait dépendre la machine est
bon a donc fait quoi là j'avais des
bouchons dans les oreilles
[Applaudissements]
démission allait pas normal koné zoumana
démission par le fait qu'alain le big
bang ici live des couteaux pas bien ça
les connaît ils roulent à jamais vu
comme un slogan il est venu il a pas
cette artère délire mais j'adorerais
jouer ont fait cas l'accent vous allez y
on essaie de trouver le coin c'est mon
frangin dans un degré qui tourne bien en
ce moment ils sont dus par les new d'un
objet comme ça avec l'accent du sud un
dernier un dernier pour la route pour
motif sérieux
oui mais ça sérieux elle connaît déjà
les trains des bagnoles j'étais très
content
il se raconte dans le truck d'une vraie
d'aluminium et une salle située dans un
truc de gouttière de place gambetta
d'oublier les gens qui nous regardent et
la ballack serait donc la banane
qu'est-ce qui se passe
et au lieu d'en voler comme la première
la première est le volet et c'est là un
plongeon de secondes après ses noces ou
bagnols une soignant est bon pour voir
ces deux machines
c'est vrai qu'on dirait que ça t'emmerde
[Rires]
et puisque à bagdad ils sont avec nous
le livre des merveilles technologiques
sur la vie des gosses immo tués
[Musique]